[Música]
como están muy buenas noches siguiendo
con la tónica emotiva y yo sé que me
salgo un poco de protocolo de té de ex
acá pero es un verdadero privilegio
compartir este escenario llevo 21 años
dando pláticas hablando de lo único que
sé que es videojuegos es un privilegio
compartir este escenario con ustedes un
aplauso para los speakers que hasta el
momento participado y los que vienen
el día de hoy si soy exitoso el día de
hoy en una conversación que tuve hace
muchos años con mi madre tuya así le
decía yo mi abuela
utilizo no me pregunten exactamente en
qué contexto la metáfora de la piedrita
mental en el zapato si soy exitoso esta
noche les voy a dejar la peli grita la
piedrita mental en el zapato de que es
posible que méxico américa latina y
particularmente un hop potencial de
desarrollo como es el estado de méxico y
toluca se conviertan en cuna de nuevos
emprendedores y de nuevos inversionistas
en la siguiente gran revolución
ahí está mi twitter por si quieren
mandar preguntas porque me dijeron que
no va haber preguntas y respuestas
esto está listo primero hablemos un poco
de lo que se dice en inglés vía love and
in the room el elefante en el cuarto de
lo que normalmente no se habla y de lo
que normalmente no se habla es que los
videojuegos son siempre o casi siempre
el malo de la película los videojuegos
son esa industria que normalmente nos
refleja mucho de lo peor que está
sucediendo en el mundo estoy hablando
particularmente de la violencia
los tics nos han enseñado o hemos
aprendido que los videojuegos hacen
referencia constante y que nos motivan
emociones que tienen que ver con
violencia y más aún con cosas que tienen
que ver con violencia o física o de
armas de fuego nada más alejado de la
realidad en esta presentación les voy a
pedir que vean mucho los números pero
sobre todo que escuchemos y analicemos
que muchos de los prejuicios pueden ser
rebatidos con las estadísticas muy
claras y la estadística que se presenta
en ese en esa plantilla es
verdaderamente clara con respecto a que
si los
años vendiéndose cada vez más pues los
crímenes relacionados con videojuegos
deberían de estar también a la alza y
como pueden ver el efecto es contrario
pero más aún hablemos de eeuu un país
que está absolutamente en un problema
social con grandes grandes números de
estadísticas que tienen que ver con
muerte por alma arma de fuego y si los
videojuegos ocasionarán esto pues japón
y corea del sur deberían de tener
también un número muy similar al de eeuu
con respecto a muertes por arma de fuego
los videojuegos no son en este sentido
los malos de la película otro elefante
en el cuarto de lo que casi no se habla
o de lo que se habla mucho pero como
prejuicio para la industria si juegas
videojuegos que da estar hubo mijito si
juegas videojuegos lo único que vas a
hacer es perder el tiempo y sobre todo
como los niños son los que juegan
videojuegos pues hay que obviamente
darles actividades adicción
que saquen mejor provecho pues tampoco
nada más alejado de la realidad 39 años
es el número que hace referencia a la
edad promedio del videojugador a nivel
mundial no son niños
yo tengo 43 años sigo jugando
videojuegos y a ustedes aunque no me
alcen la mano yo sé que por lo que estoy
viendo el 85 punto 3 por ciento de los
que están aquí juegan también
videojuegos
otro de los prejuicios los videojuegos
son para hombres si juegas videojuegos
además de todo te quedas sin novia no
nada que conste que todo el mundo está
vestido ahí para que no vayan a ver feo
47% de los videojugadores que a nivel
mundial son mujeres 47% casi 50% de las
personas que juegan videojuegos son
mujeres y no sólo eso las mujeres están
protagonizando una de las cosas más
increíbles en el mundo de la industria
de los videojuegos las competencias de
videojuegos mejor conocidas como esports
están verdaderamente siendo
apabullantemente protagonizadas por
equipos femeniles cada vez más las
mujeres están ganando campeonatos y
mucho billete ganando
y torneos de videojuegos
así que adiós al elefante en el cuarto
ahora hablemos del rey quién es el rey
de esta selva el rey de la selva
mediática el rey de la selva qué tiene
que ver con la industria de
entretenimiento interactivo los
videojuegos y por mucho a muchos de
ustedes les sorprenderá saber en esta
estadística que los videojuegos tienen
muchos años por lo menos desde el 2011
aproximadamente que generan mucho más
dinero que la industria de las películas
y la industria musical juntas y para el
2021 se espera que sea por lo menos 4
veces su tamaño lo voy a decir de nuevo
los videojuegos son una industria que
genera más dinero que todo hollywood y
que todo el mundo de la música junto
a esto hoy cuando les digo que cuando
pienso en méxico cuando pienso en
américa latina' tengo la fortuna de
vivir desde hace 10 años en una de las
zonas donde más se desarrolla tecnología
en el mundo en sillicon valley y los
mercados emergentes latinoamérica el
sudeste asiático
europa del centro este el mundo árabe
áfrica sub-sahariana y también el mundo
hispano de los eeuu el mercado hispano
de los eeuu son estos mercados
emergentes entre todos esos mercados
emergentes latinoamérica y
particularmente en méxico está
posicionado como el kínder que saque la
fotografía y de internet como un se
llama ese kinder room to grow el cuarto
para crecer eso es lo que es méxico eso
es lo que américa latina significa
alrededor de los mercados que tienen que
ver con videojuegos y entretenimiento
interactivo la oportunidad damas y
caballeros es enorme
cuáles son estos room rose estos cuartos
que creo que pueden ser verdaderamente
interesantes para emprender o para
invertir son tres la oportunidad que
presenta el desarrollo de videojuegos
independientes 2 la gran revolución que
se avecina que tiene que ver con
realidad virtual y realidad aumentada
ahora vamos a hablar de eso un poco y
tres las competencias de videojuegos los
llamados y esports hablemos primero de
spots y esports son de nuevo si hubiera
aún otro pequeño malo de la película si
los videojuegos son los malos de la
película los famosos y esports que son
las competencias de videojuegos en el
mundo se posicionaron durante mucho
tiempo por lo menos 15 años como
verdaderamente una tontería no la
tontería era el pensar que una
competencia de videojuegos pudiera ser
asociada a un fenómeno deportivo vamos a
ver de manera muy clara que desde el
2004 se hacen eventos que en este caso
es un evento que se hizo en singapur el
world cyber games que era considerado
como los juegos olímpicos de videojuegos
fue el principio de lo que hoy es una
realidad y la realidad es que tanto
audiencia como entusiastas de las
competencias de videojuegos aplastan en
números a la nfl al béisbol a la liga
mundial de béisbol y a la nba y no se
diga al hockey no voy a decir de nuevo
la audiencia que está viendo hoy
videojuegos y competencias de
videojuegos viendo o no jugando viendo
deportes electrónicos es mayor que la
nfl la nba y todos los otros los otros
deportes profesionales esto es algo
relevante y es algo que hay que tomar en
cuenta porque los números se están
acercando de manera estructurada todavía
no le llegamos a los talones pero se
están acercando al rey de los deportes
al verdadero rey de los deportes que es
el fútbol el fútbol soccer
así que los esports se presentan como
una de estos cuartos definitivamente en
franco crecimiento nosotros en méxico
tenemos una de nuestras empresas que es
la liga mexicana de videojuegos que está
haciendo torneos también desde el 2004
acabamos de abrir la liga en colombia y
definitivamente es una alternativa esta
industria o esta subcategoría de la
industria de videojuegos en la que
ustedes deberían de estar poniendo
atención a la hora de pensar en
emprendimiento o en inversión hablemos
rápidamente de realidad virtual realidad
aumentada estas realidades mixtas es
definitivamente la siguiente gran
revolución esta gráfica que no es mía
que se dice capital presenta de una
manera muy interesante como las
revoluciones tecnológicas han sido caldo
de cultivo para emprendimientos que han
cambiado el mundo lo explicó muy fácil
la revolución de la computadora personal
en los años 80 no en los años 80 y
finales de los años 80 hizo que
muchísima gente todos nosotros incluidos
tuviera una computadora personal en casa
bueno excepto hizo que muchísimas
compañías
atari apple microsoft compact etcétera
naciera la siguiente revolución se llamó
poner internet en esas computadoras y se
montó esa revolución encima de la
computadora personal y dio pie a nuevas
empresas nuevas startups que hoy son
consideradas gigantes google facebook en
su momento yahoo por supuesto a amazon
muy temprano en el en la curva y
netscape america online etcétera
etcétera qué pasó después cuando steve
jobs presentó en 2007 este dispositivo
que todos ustedes tienen en las bolsas
muy bien silenciados que sucedió cambió
al mundo porque porque sacó a internet
de la computadora personal y lo que hizo
fue montar la siguiente grande
revolución que sirvió como otro caldo de
cultivo para que vinieran otras startups
otras empresas que hoy son consideradas
los famosos unicornios über snap chat
whatsapp etcétera etcétera
otra revolución viene ya la estamos
comenzando a ver y nos estamos durmiendo
como nos hemos dormido tradicionalmente
como región latinoamérica llega tarde a
estas fiestas tenemos enfrente la
oportunidad de llegar temprano a la
siguiente gran revolución y la siguiente
gran revolución tiene que ver con muchas
tendencias definitivamente es una
revolución que representa que esta
industria va a valer 300 mil millones de
dólares hacia el 2025
vas a poder jugar videojuegos en todas
tus pantallas no importa dónde estés
esto es lo que se conoce como cloud
gaming o jugar en la nube
definitivamente los videojuegos en tus
móviles van a seguir creciendo en
calidad en potencia en entretenimiento
pero lo que me estoy refiriendo con esta
nueva revolución tiene que ver con esta
realidad superpuesta encima de lo que
tienes enfrente hoy en día lo pueden ver
con su teléfono móvil hay muchas
aplicaciones que te permiten simular
distintos objetos y super ponerlos en
una mesa o en la sala esto es apenas el
principio porque no va a ser con tu
teléfono celular con el dispositivo con
que lo vas a hacer
esto no es un vídeo pero son capturas de
un vídeo muy interesante producido por
cage y matsuda donde se pone un ejemplo
de cómo es que probablemente se vea este
futuro y no estoy hablando nada más de
un futuro para jugar videojuegos estoy
hablando de un futuro que involucra a
todas nuestras industrias un futuro que
como en su teléfono puede servir para
trabajar para entretenerse para aprender
para muchas cosas más donde creen que
está juliana restrepo en este momento
está en el transporte público y en el
transporte público tiene acceso a su
lista de compras tiene acceso obviamente
a publicidad sobre el el camión etcétera
etcétera cuando se baja del camión
incluso en obviamente no ha instalado un
anti spam porque tiene mucha publicidad
para mi gusto pero está en la calle y en
la calle está expuesta a señalamientos
de tráfico en tiempo real a publicidad
ya señalamientos de información que
tienen que ver incluso con el banco a la
hora de hacer sus compras tiene ofertas
obviamente pero también tiene una lista
de compras que puede controlar todo sin
levantar su teléfono esto es algo que va
a suceder les guste o no les guste si
hay o hace 10 años les hubiera dicho que
iban a tener en su teléfono
absolutamente todo lo que tenían en su
computadora personal a lo mejor muchos
de ustedes no me hubieran querido y
mucho si ustedes me hubieran dicho yo
nunca mario'
ok
hasta los productos van a ser
susceptibles de darte información cómo
se va a ver esto oye mario yo no me
imagino caminando por el súper con esta
madre en la cabeza no
y mucho menos con esta forma es cool que
se vea no me imagino bueno yo te diría
tienes mala memoria
tienes muy mala memoria porque si yo te
hubiera dicho que iba a estar checando
internet en esta cosa pues te hubieran
seguido a mí no esto es apenas el
principio y de lo que estoy hablando es
que algo como lo que están viendo en
pantalla va a suceder y es la siguiente
gran revolución incluso me gusta pensar
yo no lo sé que podría ser así
donde este dispositivo se conecta
inalámbricamente en tu móvil y te
presente la información que juliana
restrepo nos acaba de mostrar esto se
presenta como una gran oportunidad
incluso para videojuegos pero para todas
estas ciento otras industrias salud
entretenimiento ingeniería eventos en
vivo entrenamiento recursos humanos
pongámonos las pilas latinoamérica y los
mercados emergentes tienen el potencial
de llegar temprano a esta fiesta no
intenten emprender en mobil no intenten
fundar el siguiente la siguiente
aplicación que va a cambiarlo todo en
mobil porque ese tren ya se nos fue este
no ha llegado y definitivamente va a ser
muy importante hacer dos cosas una
emprender alrededor de esta nueva ola
pero la otra invertir en esta nueva ola
si no hay inversión no hay
emprendimiento que está pasando con el
mercado actualmente
además de trabajar en lo que trabajo en
videojuegos llevo 10 años invirtiendo en
el mercado bursátil me ha dado la
visibilidad para poder aprender que el
ciclo histórico de los mercados hace que
sea muy evidente que se avecina tarde o
temprano no sé si en el 2020 o en el
2021 sería de un millonario y además no
les diría
cuando es la siguiente gran el gran
declive del mercado donde es muy barato
invertir no sé cuándo pero va a suceder
en ese momento emprendedores e
inversionistas es cuando históricamente
se alinean si ustedes le preguntan a
empresas que hoy son consideradas
unicornios como uber o como spotify o
como el bien vi cuando recibieron su
primera inversión fue justamente cuando
el mercado estaba en el piso
completamente cuando a todo el mundo le
daba miedo invertir los invito aquí a
toluca porque soy toluco y porque
hablando específicamente de la metáfora
anulados que me parece fantástica
alrededor de este evento mi sueño es que
el estado de méxico se convierta en un
hub de desarrollo que llegue temprano a
esta fiesta y que se le ponga al tiro a
otros hop de desarrollo en latinoamérica
y en méxico están empezando a
mover esta piedrita de zapato mental
jobs como jalisco como baja california
como yucatán como aguascalientes
próximamente querétaro el estado de
méxico tiene el potencial de llegar
temprano esta fiesta les agradezco mucho
el tiempo
[Aplausos]